E aí
[Música]
e se houvesse certeza o futuro seria
desinteressante eu vou falar para vocês
sobre como vai ser o nosso futuro
Olá eu sou futurista de nascença
e eu já vivi muitas vidas dentro dessa
vida sempre muito à frente do meu tempo
e eu confesso que quando me perguntam
quem eu sou e o que eu faço meu cérebro
colapsa porque eu não sei explicar
direito meu trabalho eu sou muitas
coisas para dizer que eu sou uma coisa
só
e noventa porcento das pessoas buscam
garantias sobre o amanhã E acho
insuportável viver sem previsão
os futuristas não fazem previsão
se traduzem sinais de futuros para criar
empatia entusiasmo com tudo aquilo que
nós podemos criar daqui até lá
e eu estou aqui hoje para mostrar para
vocês a beleza da incerteza
bom e como ela pode nos alavancar para
sonhos grandiosos e depois nos fazer
voltar para o presente sem ansiedade do
que ainda não aconteceu
e eu nasci no Rio Grande do Sul numa
cidade do interior
a filha de telefonista e professor o
nosso futuro era muito nosso dia a dia é
muito simples Digno correto os muito
simples nossa vida não tinha grandes
Ambições
e foi crescendo inquieta espaçosa
querendo descobrir mais o mundo
é mas para gente como eu o futuro era um
ilustre desconhecido e provavelmente
Medíocre estudar casar de casa própria
filho e depois descansar na
aposentadoria era isso que os adultos
faziam naquela época uma vida cheia de
possibilidades era só para ricos e
Poderosos
e eu fui percebendo que aquilo criava
uma vida muito limitada para quase todas
as pessoas que eu conhecia
É mas não conseguiu sonhar porque nos
ensinavam que a gente só pode dar passo
certo
G1
hoje aos 24 anos eu perdi meu pai no
Estalo
e eu perguntei onde está a Vida Segura
que me ensinaram a viver
é especialmente aquela onde o pai e a
mãe da gente não morre nunca
e eu descobri com bastante dor que essa
vida não existe e que garantias nos
levam para uma vida atrofiada
e o trauma da perda me fez tomar
decisões muito importantes porque eu vi
o meu pai com olhos de medo porque ele
não tinha vivido a vida que ele poderia
ter vivido
e naquele minuto eu decidi que a minha
vida seria diferente sim que eu teria
várias vidas dentro de uma vida só
Oi e que eu me jogaria Na incerteza
experimentar ia tudo que a vida me
apresenta
eu mudei de casa de emprego de trabalho
de marido de cidade
Oi e a cada salto para o novo a minha
história ficando mais interessante
e na minha experiência numa das minhas
encarnações profissionais como Colt
e em 3 mil horas de conversas sobre
desafios eu vi que as pessoas engavetam
sonho
bom e fica uma caixinha
tô procurando certezas
é uma vida atrofiada procurando
respostas e acham esse lugar fora da
caixa insuportavelmente arriscado
é porque muita gente já não deu certo e
arriscar é só para doido
e como estrategista e futurista minha
pesquisa de campo me mostrou de novo que
dentro do ambiente Empresarial ambição é
tão pequena tão pobre tão limitada
e as pessoas têm medo de sonhar grande
é porque dinheiro todo mundo faz
diferença não
e nas minhas palestras o tempo todo me
perguntam como será o futuro como se eu
soubesse
E a minha resposta é sempre a mesma não
sei
bom então por que que você estuda o
futuro para garantir que eu não vou
morar numa caixinha e eu não vou ter uma
vida atrofiada para libertar a minha
imaginação
um dos projetos que eu faço os gestores
me perguntam como é que nós vamos ter
certeza de que a escolha que estamos
fazendo será acerta
hoje e todos os dias eu encontro pessoas
que contam para mim como se sentem
impotentes frente às incertezas do mundo
e o mundo vai ficar cada vez mais
difícil cada vez mais intenso cada vez
mais imprevisível a gente vive uma era
sem precedentes
e é uma transformação radical e
exponencial gostando você diz ou não
é mas pela primeira vez nós temos a
chance de juntos construir o futuro que
a gente tanto deseja um planeta
restaurado e dignidade para todas as
pessoas em harmonia com todas as
espécies do nosso mundo o sonho é muito
difícil de vender o anti sonho é mais
comercial
é porque o povo tem medo porque as
pessoas têm medo e por que não somos
treinados para viver uma vida de medo
é só que medrosos não constroem
histórias extraordinárias e nem
biografias respeitadas e
é porque a gente quer saber tanto o que
vem amanhã se a gente nunca soube
chegamos até aqui
e eu passo muito dos meus dias tentando
destravar as pessoas na sua imaginação
é porque elas só conseguem se preocupar
com manter o que existe ou Cuidado que
eu construir e o sonho vai ficando pobre
o Imagine você como seria a sua vida se
você soubesse que não tem futuro algum
esperando por você
G1
Olá eu sou professora de Formação fui
executiva
Eu me formei como estrategista estou
futurista desenvolvi minha
espiritualidade quando meu pai morreu
usei todas as filosofias e doutrinas que
tentam explicar como a nossa vida
funciona quem nós somos porque a gente
tá aqui e por que que o futuro é um
lugar que vale a pena
e eu viajei para outra cama para Roma
para o Oriente Médio para Israel Japão
Tailândia e um dia na minha aula de
kabbalah que é uma palavra Hebraica que
traduzido para o português significa
receber conhecimento
e eu ouvi um doido falando que velhice
era doença
bom e que em breve Não teremos mais
morte
e enquanto eu olhava para as pessoas
chocadas com aquela notícia aqui dentro
o monte de luzinhas começaram a piscar e
eu pensei ah disse que eu quero falar
e eu mergulhei intensamente nesse mundo
de estudo de futuros que é onde moram
todas as incertezas do mundo
e a incerteza é um insumo para o
futurista e Ela nos permite viajar com
Liberdade
e para coisas ridículas inimagináveis
absurdas
e impensáveis
e ela nos dá essa liberdade a incerteza
porque não a trava para nada as apostas
precisam ser feitas se não o nosso mundo
vai continuar colapsado e medíocre
e que tipo de coisas nós precisamos
criar Inovar e pouco e não vai fazer um
puxadinho numa casa velha a gente
precisa Inovar e além e pensar em coisas
muito estranhas muito estranhas
e o medo nos atrofia
é a garantia faz com que a gente recue e
não se jogue nesse jogo intenso da vida
que acontece todos os dias à nossa volta
futuristas falam de coisas muito
esquisitas camas medbed que escaneia no
seu corpo e que já tratam todas as
possíveis doenças que podem aparecer
o transumanos
e a beleza das novas décadas
ou será que a gente vai ser assim 2050
a morar em Marte quem pensa nisso
e o futuro do mundo daqui a 500 anos
é a vida nos desafia todos os dias e um
dia
é exatamente em 2019 o futuro fechou as
portas para mim
Ah e eu não tinha mais futuro nem certo
nem perto
E aí
Tô voltando da Austrália onde eu fui
estudar futuros
e eu descobri um câncer
e eu apaixonadíssima pela vida saudável
e é muito difícil saber que existe uma
doença dentro de você que só termina
quando você acaba e que se você ouve
todas as coisas que falam a morte é
certa
e nada do que disseram que era certo
aconteceu é certo que a genético não foi
se é certo que a mutação de gene não foi
mas a morte é certa
e chocada comecei a aceitar que a partir
de Então vai fazer a parte do clube dos
pacientes oncológicos aqueles que ficam
magros carecas com olheira
tô sofrendo que não tem nada mais para
viver a não ser esperar a morte de um
dia vir uma história lutou contra o
câncer tantos anos
a processar
e é muito difícil mas tem um sabor
é um dia nas minhas meditações eu ouvi
uma voz não era do além era minha
própria voz
é uma voz de alguém que mora aqui dentro
que me disse seguinte vamos olhar isso
de uma outra forma esse é um presente da
vida para você
e você vai ter a linda oportunidade de
experimentar uma doença grave de dentro
de se entregar para incerteza e de
contar para as pessoas que não é tão
ruim assim
e eu decidi mudar esse evento que são
Capítulo da minha vida
e eu passei a amar minha doença eu
passei a conversar com as minhas células
eu li tudo sobre o assunto eu encontrei
histórias extraordinárias
G1
Oi e eu fiz tudo que eu podia fazer para
que a doença fosse um pouco mais amena
é um pouco mais tranquila dentro de mim
o que a gente está sem imagem
G1
é a desculpa gente estão vendo
e Essa sou eu
e durante a minha quimioterapia
e Essa sou eu Durante a minha vida do
ano passado essa sou eu no palco sem que
ninguém soubesse que eu tinha câncer
é a minha vida ficou enorme a minha
experiência ficou gigante
e eu descobri que Na incerteza que a
gente da grandes saltos para o futuro um
paciente de câncer ele tem um grande
desejo a cura
Oi e ele tem zero garantia sobre que vai
acontecer no dia seguinte e a gente
precisa viver o incerto sem perder a
esperança e sem querer atropelar o nosso
passo
e as pessoas querem garantias e quando
elas me perguntam quais garantias Elas
têm eu respondo nenhuma
é um dia um cliente disse para mim que
eu ficava falando que ele tava riscar
aqui então ele iria arriscar
é mas caso ele precisasse voltar se ele
poderia voltar se não der certo eu falei
claro que pode Vou fazer um café para
gente para esperar você
o Ufa ainda bem diz porque
é porque eu não posso nem pensar em me
arriscar e não tem ninguém para culpar
não poder dividir a dor do meu fracasso
com alguém
e eu respondi para ele que tal se
responsabilizar pelo seu fracasso e
dividiu seu fracasso com o mundo inteiro
inaceitável você com as suas ideias e
ele foi embora
É eu sei que ele tentou e fracassou e eu
sei que ele tentou de novo e fracassou
de novo e um dia ele me ligou muito
tempo depois
e me disse o seguinte Agora eu entendi o
que você quer dizer com a beleza da
incerteza
e eu tô livre eu queria o coisas novas
todos os dias eu adoro
E obrigada por continuar comigo enquanto
eu saltava nesse abismo
eu era muito importante eu saber
eu tinha alguém lá para me ouvir caso é
fracassar se caso eu fosse tomado como
um incompetente E a minha resposta foi
somos todos incompetentes Em algum
momento da vida
o Leonardo da Vinci disse que de tempos
em tempos a gente passa por um esse
formato
em um período onde a vida fica turva
Nebulosa sem chão sem resposta e se você
tiver musculatura para sentar nesse
lugar em certo o que se revela depois
pode ser extraordinário
e eu aprendi muito com a minha doença
hoje eu fui para o lugar ainda maior
E no momento mais difícil da minha vida
eu entendi onde Nós criamos o futuro
aquele futuro que a gente deseja não
qualquer futuro
e quando a gente mergulha na beleza da
Incerteza e na abundância da adversidade
bom é quando a gente começa a construir
a roda daquilo que a gente realmente
quer porque a gente entra no jogo da
vida pra valer
e como observadores atentos a todas as
possibilidades eu espero que a minha
história
me ajude você até menos certeza Das
incertezas do mundo
e eu espero que a minha história ajude
você a curar sua mente dessa busca
Insana pelo que vai acontecer amanhã não
existe essa resposta
o enamore-se da incerteza
e é por ela que o futuro começa muito
obrigada
E aí